all this yes hoofs appealing to the
young right if you're over 40 I into
this if you're over 50 I think so I
think if you look at behavior let me ask
you a question have you noticed some of
you're over 40 over 50 friends start to
send emojis on text I don't know what it
is do you know the little poop pictures
and a little face and a smile some text
well listen let's turn off the cameras
we got things to do here
I need Larry to send some poop emojis
immediately a poop emoji yes
poop emoji is the next thing I could do
in the next in the next segment we're
gonna talk poop emojis but I look I
think if you look at the data it's
stunning what's happened 35 to 60 I'll
go a different route with you it for
anybody who's watching right now if
you're lucky enough to know your parent
at the age that you are now if you're at
an age where you actually knew your mom
and dad at the same age you are now you
will notice that your behavior is much
younger much younger that has a lot to
do with technology technologies clanging
people were living through a Uthoff
ocation of our society the
fastest-growing segment on the
instagrams and the snapchats of the
world are the 40 in overs because just
like Facebook these things age up